we're used to seeing McKenzie Ziggler's
smiling face and awesome dance moves
which is why we were so stunned to see
her crying on Instagram live they can
see once called her now ex-boyfriend
Isaac Presley perfect but there has to
be a reason they broke up we'll fill you
in on what we know so far and let you
know what Mackenzie has asked from her
fans during this difficult time if your
reaction to seeing Mackenzie looking
gloom is to hop on Isaac's social media
and let him have it wait we totally
understand the impulse but it's
definitely not what Mackenzie would want
some fans notice that the formerly happy
couple went from showing up in each
other's social media to seemingly taking
some time apart
despite dealing with a painful breakup
Mackenzie hated feeling like she was
being dishonest to her fans by not being
upfront about her relationship status I
just I hated lying to you guys and even
though they're not together anymore
Mackenzie and Isaac are clearly still in
touch since she texted him to make sure
it was okay for her to share the truth
with her fans I just I hated lying to
you guys I had literally just texted him
I was like kind please just tell
everyone because since Mackenzie is
still so considerate of her ex's
feelings it might not surprise you to
know that they apparently didn't part on
bad terms although many fans speculated
Isaac could be to blame for their split
Mackenzie set the record straight by
saying he didn't do anything
apparently the pair didn't part on bad
terms because Mackenzie clarified that
the two are still good friends
after all of this in fact she still
cares for him deeply despite the fact
that they're no longer together I really
really really love him like with all my
heart
Isaac is still an important person to
Mackenzie and it's likely her family
feels the same way
obviously Mackenzie and her sister
Maddie are super close and she was
friends with Isaac as well he even let
her do his makeup so it's safe to say
he's pretty good friends with her family
although Maddy hasn't said anything
about the split yet we have no doubt
she'll support her sister no matter what
despite what Mackenzie said during her
Instagram life there are some fans who
suspect Isaac of stepping out on her
during their relationship back in March
2020 Nicolette gray
uploaded a video in which one of her
friends cold claimed they spent some
alone time with a Disney Channel star
and youtuber although she didn't say out
loud that the person was Isaac the video
made it pretty obvious who was being
talked about allegedly Isaac presented
himself as single and fans were furious
about what he had done to Mackenzie but
according to Mackenzie that didn't
happen she stated that she had been with
Isaac on the dates in question and that
they spent so much time together either
on the phone or in person he wouldn't
have had time to flirt with anyone else
Isaac also defended himself saying that
people were just trying to ruin the
happiness he shared with Mackenzie and
that he had done nothing wrong the
couple presented a strong unified front
in the face of these allegations
Mackenzie even shared a video featuring
Isaac just to make it clear that they
were still together and feeling good
about their relationship back then
Mackenzie specifically asked her fans to
stay out of their relationship while she
said she appreciates the love people
have for her and that they've got her
back she claimed to be able to handle
her own relationship
Mackenzie also said that nobody
commenting really knew the full story of
what was going on between them Isaac
accused someone of trying to share this
story in a way that would bring
attention to themselves he claimed to be
in love with Mackenzie and said he
wouldn't do anything to jeopardize their
relationship despite the rumours that
plagued the end of their relationship
Mackenzie made it clear that she doesn't
feel Isaac has done anything wrong and
she still cares deeply for him as a
friend
no one
anything even though a lot of us had
seen it coming it was easy to be happy
for the new couple who seemed to be
totally head-over-heels with each other
they even put their relationship to the
test by filming a video where Mackenzie
had to answer trivia questions about
Isaac although she definitely didn't get
a perfect score on the so-called
girlfriend test it was clear that these
two were seriously cute and very smitten
with each other Mackenzie confirmed that
the two first started dating in New York
and the first trip they took together
was in Vegas back when things were good
Isaac said Mackenzie was the sweetest
person he'd ever met and admitted that
his pet name for her was monkey face
Mackenzie said there wasn't anything
about Isaac she didn't like and that his
best quality is a sense of humor even
though they're no longer together it's
clear Mackenzie still cares for him and
asked her fans to stay out of the
situation
Isaac admitted that he has been
receiving terrible DMS from Mackenzie's
fans and asked them to leave him alone
as much as it hurts to see Mackenzie
feeling down the best thing her fans can
do right now is give her space and
respect his wishes do you think Isaac
and Mackenzie are done for good or do
you think they'll find their way back
together did this breakup surprise you
or did you see it coming a mile away
share your thoughts with us in the
comment section and don't forget to
click subscribe for more videos from the
things thanks for watching we'll see you
again next time
[Music]